[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship july
29th
momenthouse.com tinymeatgang tell them
what we're doing we're doing it's going
to be so much fun we got dj's head from
spock we got a live
that's cringe we're doing a new cody
noel do we're premiering it no one's
ever seen it we learned how to sword
fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and we got
some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
might have some special guests drop by
all around good time
so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for 24
hours
after the show happens so in case you
bought a ticket but you miss it you can
still watch it for the day after but
after that
this finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
momenthouse.com
oh yeah you wanna just you wanna kid
cuddy the whole situation look at this
oh is it
kid cut what is it dark oh yeah this is
on his tik tok
and it's not taken down which blows my
mind
we don't realize who i finally got
to see what the [ __ ]
me after my what the [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah he's not he's not a comedian
so what's going on here i think this is
his way of saying like
i'm just like here i'm being creepy yeah
this is him just saying
uh philosophically i am a pedophile
weird
i think that's what this is finally 18
bro
that's that's the that sentence right
there the fact and
the fact that he types that and he's
still like a free man walking around
jesus christ dude
i don't know bro i just so i
i never watched any like videos about
this guy or anything he sucks man
does he i was just compelled to signal
boost this because i just can't believe
that
this is a person yeah yeah
yeah god forbid anyone brings a kid near
this man jesus christ
um a lot of his content
i think originally was just sort of
cringe
lip syncing but it turned into like
bragging his like
phrase is where am i where are you i'll
always be like where am i
and where are you i'm at the hard rock
literally that was me at 9 00 a.m the
other morning where am i
and where are you kelsey where are you
right now where am i where are you
babe i'm at the hard rock so she's like
i'm my man
dave dealing me cards
yeah his thing is like i have 750
000 worth of chains on he always has
three hundred dollar nikes
look i mean his profile what is he doing
i don't know how's he making how does he
have 750k worth of chains
i mean click that one on the top left
that first one
so i'm always fake flexing huh i just
got one question for all my haters at
home
where am i and where are you
i'm in myrtle beach south carolina
oh yeah no i know that is not a fun
place dude
you should not be bragging about going
there oh i knew that was going to hit
like a bomb
i do it's like holy [ __ ]
where am i where are you where are you
i'm at myrtle beach right now oh damn
i'd rather be [ __ ] not even on the
same planet as myrtle beach
[Laughter]
where am i where are you i'm in van nuys
california
at a bus stop
seven hundred fifty thousand dollars
worth of chains on please believe
three hundred dollar nikes that's so
funny my friend had to take a red eye to
myrtle beach yesterday night
he's like i gotta get on a [ __ ]
red-eye flight tonight we're like where
he's like myrtle beach we're like
oh damn
taking a red eye and waking up in myrtle
beach dog
wait close this and go to the one over
this next one
i don't know if it'll be as good as that
but this one killed me
where am i and where are you the stars
are in the building bring your sharpies
what's up miami come get me free
autographs
all night bring your sharpies what
he said that hashtag
floyd mayweather hashtag logan paul vs
floyd mayweather so on the night of that
fight
he was promoting himself being there and
he said
stars are in the building bring your
sharpies
free autographs what yeah
what yeah keep going i got a key i got
to see more of this guy
do you though i got i know i want i want
more myrtle beach
[ __ ] like he's talking about like
he's making the eating out hand to 18
year olds yeah that's
i mean that's [ __ ] up but i just this
guy's like is he wearing makeup and all
these too
uh i can't there's a faked hand and he's
got the eyebrows done
yeah he's got a really bizarre look a
lot of self-grooming
i don't know how many of these he speaks
in
um go wait go up
no nevermind that no go down a little
bit that one on the left does it have a
[ __ ] ton of views no
no no go right below it
nah never mind if i said million yeah he
always needs
some fake flexing huh
oh here we go go to the one where he's
walking down the street
in next to the green oh no he's
lip-syncing
dude his beard in that it's crazy oh my
god
the good thing is is he's easily
identified weirdo
he's easily identified yeah exactly
hey man uh there's a man here with a
go-kart sticker fade on his beard
hard rock nick yes hard rock nick
oh yeah don't worry we'll be over there
stat also so absurd and name yourself
after the hard rock yeah
it's like yeah man i'm applebee's cody
so they call me because i'm always there
dog
yeah i'm best buy bobby yeah exactly
dude he really looks like a go-kart i'm
[ __ ] i'm
a picture it always comes back to
karting doesn't it
it does but it always comes back look
like look at that profile like those
hard ass lines
dude the [ __ ] off he really does why who
who would even do that you just kind of
beat box right there who
no you're like a what what
hard drive nick who would even do that
design
i mean like if you walked in you were
like can i get this i'd be like
no what no
yo making me look like a race car oh we
got one of those sae boys
yeah yep yeah i mean vaguely
dude no no it does it does it finally oh
my god bro
what if your cart was here no
i'm just more just the line in his
[ __ ] face
click that one it kills me man yeah
that's what i always do and they never
catch me ain't nobody gonna catch me
because you're too street wise yo
and all these hoes laughing like so
funny she's talking about the audience
that they're laughing at her did did you
say all right you can you can
fully close this i hate it i
hate it yeah
[Laughter]
i mean dude what is that
like he took like one of those like
fuzzy pipe cleaners and just like laid
it
perfectly around his face they
programmed that [ __ ] on matlab
perfect yo can you use matlab to draw
the dumbest beard ever
this is our new race card design cool i
want that on my face
what do you want man just give me the
dumbest [ __ ] you can possibly think of
like just go freehand and [ __ ] it up
really just go in what the
hell what the [ __ ] was that yours okay
yo what do you want man um make it look
like i left a space helmet on way too
long
like you know man yeah [ __ ] that guy